chers amis chers républicain permettez
moi en tant que secrétaire général du
comité les outre-mer et au nom de
l'ensemble de mes collègues de travail
de vous faire part de l'émotion et de
l'honneur ce sont les miens de
m'exprimer parce avons en ce jour si
important pour notre mouvement
et pour la france notre président
nicolas sarkozy nous a appelés à
participer à l'alternance au
redressement de la france
les autres maires ont toute leur place
dans le processus de reconquête au sein
des républicains
oui les autres maires sont la république
nous sommes la france enfants de prendre
de victor hugo du général de gaulle
d'aimé césaire vous de félix éboué
nous portons dans notre coeur est en
notre adn la république
mes chers amis avec et les publicains
nous développerons le potentiel
remariage de notre histoire d'outre-mer
par les autant de politiques spécifiques
et adaptées pour que nous une trame ares
1 soyons les véritables acteurs de notre
avenir avec les républicains nous
redonnerons espoir à notre jeunesse
souvent désabusés par un chômage sans
précédent avec les républicains nous
accordons une attention particulière à
ce que les ultramarins de la métropole
16 être considérés comme des fous
de seconde jambe et qu'ils puissent
s'épanouir dans leur pays la france
en outre mer nous construirons notre
futur avec ce qui nous rassemble les
valeurs de la république
derrida suivant de notre action avec
notre président nicolas sarkozy et
l'ensemble des républicains
rassemblons nous soyons unis et partons
à la rencontre de nos territoires
d'outre-mer vivre les autres merdes
vive la république et vive la fin